squeeze aujourd'hui se trouvaient neuf
fois sur le cul street pour jouer un jeu
d'horreur c'est parti lost in the ride
c'est le nom du jeu non ce n'est pas mon
prénom est ouvre-toi [ __ ] je suis prêt
à pratiquer au nom à pratiquer alain du
tout si ça se passe comme ça les gens là
un téléphone qui nous invite une
distance d'accord avec une main il ya
des yeux par terre à danser les gouttes
d'eau très bien de kiev où qu'on aille
par la 87e je dois ramasser des notes
très bien x bay ford health insights
over the last time avec chamakh sont
carrément exagéré de type américain ok
ce qu'il faut faire au final 1 ce qu'on
va retrouver encore autour de cadavres
où je pense qu'il faut trouver des
cailloux mois ces cailloux la regarde et
je vais arriver hop ça passe à autre
chose
voilà exactement ce que tu as fait ça
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une petite page on
nous laisse sur la fin du roman c'est
scandaleux 107 mètres tout droit faut
suivre la lune c'est parfait l'une guide
mois ah non c'est pas une racaille ou
cailloux guide mois branche ne me tue
pas marre contre 170 m [ __ ] mais c'est
quoi c'est un marathon l'a carrément
bonsoir je fais un marathon seul en
pleine nuit alors qu'il pleure une forêt
vide qui suis-je qui suis-je un jeu
d'horreur c'est une grotte c'est ça très
bien ni quel est ce qu'une personne n'a
confiance en cette grotte
non il faut y aller l'as givet à
reculons pour finalement me trouvais
droit sortie des quartiers ah mais gps
dit qu'il faut aller dans les quartiers
ça tombe bien besoin quel gps te dirai
sordi sylvie tu vas mourir
il ya eu un bruit j'aime pas situer on
dirait un visage au loin même si on
dirait pas comme ça ça on s'enfonce
carrément dans le sol ça sent jamais bon
le casse la bouteille pour être prêt
mais gorges avant même de m'avoir vu
quoi tout va bien il a senti ma présence
je ne le sens pas bien est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un quelque chose un animal de
compagnie par tout hasard un chat le
chat à regarder on l'entend je suis
certain qu est un [ __ ] de chats dans
ces conduits au
ok c'était que ça c'est une femme
c'était tel dans les conduits en fait on
aussi la fin du roman
oh c'était la fumée j'ai cru que c'était
un petit scarabée absolument pas j'ai
cru que c'était une sorte de gros
monstres bien géant avec une hache
kaleme de couper en 2 littéralement faut
que j'aille ou du coup ça y est je
deviens fou dans cette quête est ce une
peluche [ __ ] et orange carnage
on va avoir la peau du putois
illégalement énervante cantat lundi
forme bouge
bon c'est une peluche salut à ses 16 ans
le problème quand même
mais non elle est là pour nous guider
voilà elle nous guide alors de manière
un peu chelou puisqu'elle s'était lui
porte et qu'on la trouve plus pendant 10
minutes mais c'est une sorte de guide
très bien donc notre guide s'est fait
tuer les sétois mais oui c'est elle vous
l'avez vu j'ai vu au loin je vais me
perds je vais me perdre
qu'est ce qu'il ya il y avait un bruit
de l est et la dent ou c'est carrément
halluciné eux ou alors je suis à moitié
aveugle aux ya un petit bruit comme si
quelqu'un avait claqué les fesses de
saab et de son copain ou fermer un livre
aussi ce qui est large et moi rien à
voir en soi oui ça descend bien par là
ça sent la mort par là or vous avez y
avait une sorte de une petite fille qui
samedi a joué à chaque hall au plafond
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie personnelle
mme hanska camsa de sa vie qu'il quitte
cette vidéo et qu'il se rende au poste
de police le plus proche de chez lui
office j'ai besoin d'une clé c'est ce
qu'il a dit l'histoire devant m
quelqu'un est mort c'est génial ça comme
gps de gps qui te dit où sont les morts
quoi attention dans 25 mètres un cadavre
se trouve au pied de l'arbre ça suffit
donc c'est à 16 m là bas c'est là
quelqu'un est mort donne côté de ce mur
ne trouverait jeunes cadavres
taku peu marre j'ai cru qu'ils avaient
un but pour que des fois j'ai eu chaud
gars des trucs à nokia rien de faire des
trucs que je les vois pas qu'est ce que
c'est que ça mon cerveau fait absolument
n'importe quoi pourquoi quand on dit pas
cléac'h se manifeste pas besoin ouais
donc j'ai douze tous seraient dans fort
boyard quoi où et la clé 10 et récupère
la sauf que là ya pas des preuves
ça c'est une chambre à coucher mais
peut-être avait déjà gâché la clé sous
le matelas
bien sûr que non y'a juste du sang sous
le matelas comme david au fisc and what
c'était improbable quoi attendait déjà
vous prenez pas de juger monsieur
trouver la clé j'en ai marre branscombe
rappelé tout le temps j'en ai marre
alors on sait qu'il ya un cadavre au
mieux on remonte c'est la sortie tu es
là confort repenser fait un pas en
arrière où tu ne quittera plus jamais
cet endroit mais déjà j'ai envie de
quitter un étrangement parce que c'est
très loin les disneyland ici qu'elle
tous les sites b c'est parfait ça le
panneau qui était au tout début il ya 20
minutes ou à la porte ou à la porte ou à
la porte
est ce qu'elle a fait un petit caprice
elle s'est transformée en étagères non
mais [ __ ] ou à la porte un numéro
c'est une énigme
voilà là cela on est en plein coeur de
fort boyard c'est bon ou pas c'est bon
pas s'il vous plaît fallait sortir en
arrière on sait que sur le papier il
avait marqué repenser effet non non non
il n'y a pas marqué sa vie tout sur
papier meurt lentement et 10 et si je
mourais rapidement d'un coup sec sur la
nuque je cours je cours je sais pas où
aller mais je coure mon gars est
monsieur porte mon nom n'y a rien de mon
gars ya juste des gens qui crient nous
encourons après l'annoncé par terre il
dit traîner dans les conduits dans ce
quart à la poussée violemment de stoch
candidats précisément d'ailleurs on en
est là je ne sais pas quoi lui dire
salut quel est ton peuple a préféré elle
va me tuer au nom
elle m'a enfermée dans la pièce enfin
junte et je suis désolé je parle un
décibel
bon déjà cette fois je vais pas attendre
pour m'assurer qu'elle me suis un là
j'espère ne pas tomber dans un cul de
sac ou dans une pièce sombre et glauque
là c'est bon j'ai trouvé le chemin saint
louis au [ __ ] jamais été aussi content
de voir des marches menant pourtant
d'habitude tu fais la gueule d'habitude
je suis plutôt un petit sur les
séducteurs à l'ascenseur à on s'enfuit
on va retrouver nos potes les cailloux
qui se prennent pour des lunes
alors que ce sont des cailloux pauvres
de même bon c'est moi la [ __ ] c'est
non mais là c'est le chat le plus au
monde commencé quand y en a un des deux
qui s'essouffle haletant réfléchir
et merde j'aurais peut-être dû à l'état
de test et par qui font ce à quoi à
temps je me mouche pendant ce temps je
te plaît quand même c'est une dure
journée de travail pour moi en tant que
porte la sortie brouilla 2 j'aimerais
arriver à destination à jour gps pas de
signal [ __ ] de gps
rien de mieux qu'un marathon en forêt
pour se ressourcer au y avait une tasse
de au nom qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait de
pousser des courriers ne la voit pas ses
filles et voulait aller plus loin il
tente rend chez le médecin au couteau
sans plus forte plus no signal égale
mort rabutin équation du génie c'est
donc toi le mort j'appelle mes cousins
peu plus mignonne mais tu es celle qu'on
a vu plein de fois mondiaux enfin ma
fille
qu'attends tu de moi oh elle revit elle
revit elle revit non on va jouer à chat
on continue à bombay at il soufflé en
premier donc tout est calme et et c'est
la fin c'est la fin de la sienne juif je
propose qu'on enchaîne avec un deuxième
petit jeu d'horreur alone in the wrist
voilà c'est presque la même chose il ya
faria le mot rift donc c'est précis même
chose bref ça commence en pleine forêt
dirais que j'ai un téléphone
non
je n'ai pas de billets non plus bon je
propose qu'on se dirige vers la lumière
de manière bien bien normal toujours
ceux des bienveillantes haut avec le qg
absents faire un peu de luge
mais de la luge au ralenti kouao oui je
vois quelque chose là-bas au loin
c'est de l'eau c'est quoi non c'est le
sol mais alors si flou voilà j'aime ce
genre de bug mental mais puissance mille
bonsoir lampadaires troisième du nom oh
oh c'est une maison carrément la kabbale
les ministres et il ya une ombre il ya
une ombre vous la voyez je la vois vous
la voyez nous la voyons elle attend
comme ça face au mur comme si quelqu'un
sur cette planète s'amuser attendre face
au mur toute la journée toute la nuit ne
me tue pas tu m'a pas tué c'est bien
c'est bien tu respectes et à part du
marché
j'aime pas trop le broutage comme ça
avec qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et aucun
but de [ __ ] y'a pas des pages c'est
pas des cailloux des silex par un ford
truc je reste dans la cabane
je fais comme toi orolia j'attends
j'attends contraint un mur en bois non
mais pourquoi la musique au monde la
belge est aisément non non non non non
non non ça met la pression je déteste ça
mais quel orchestre accepté de faire ce
sont de faux cailloux vas-y je me
réjouis à part qu'est ce que tu attends
deux mois qu'est ce que tu regardais
samu aux [ __ ] annoncé une cheminée
tu veux que je fasse un feu je vais te
faire un peu ma douce ah bon je crois tu
es tout droit ok en sortant de la cabane
oui ça suffit à tout se calme je ferai
ton feu un peu plus tard bon je pense
qu'on a eu notre dose de mort pour ce
soir j'espère que ce ne sera plus si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
ça fera vraiment plaisir c'est carrément
bizarre mais avec le plus riche j'arrive
à trouver du plaisir à jouer à un jeu
d'horreur avoir cette sensation de
faiblesse voilà de faiblesse parce qu'on
fout carrément rien le fait assez
monstrueux par contre ils peuvent bien
nous déchirer un ca à l'eau près le
monstre on se retrouve très vite à la
nouvelle vidéo chat ou le monde
pis